How would you say urgent?
Urgente.
good.
How would you say urgently?
Urgentemente.
I love you in Spanish is te quiero.
Literally, I want you.
You might have also heard te amo.
You should be uh weary of this difference.
Takiero you can use with friends, you can use with uh lovers very soon.
Tamo is much, much more serious.
But uh tekiero is very common and it literally means I want you.
So te is you, we can get rid of this and here we are left with I want.
Quiero.
Quiero. Good, how would you say I don't want?
No quiero.
Good, we just put no before.
One of my favorite rules for convertible words is the rule for words ending I-O-N.
This is an extremely useful rule.
Words ending I-O-N are the same in English and Spanish.
Just in Spanish they have the accent on the end.
So for example, in English we have opinion and in Spanish you're going to pronounce syllable by syllable, making sure that you're pronouncing the vowels as they're written and you're going to put the accent on the end.
Opinion.
Good.
Passion.
Good when you pronounce the s because we don't like sh
Preparation now if it's shun T-I-O-N if we have shun it's gonna be C-I-O-N in Spanish and this C-I-O-N is pronounced
Sion, like an S in most of the Spanish-speaking world, or in most of Spain, it's pronounced Zion.
So you can choose if you have a particular affiliation for Spain, you can make this th.
If not, I uh suggest using the S sound because the majority of Spanish speakers are using this sound, and it's also much easier.
It doesn't appear difficult here.
Preparacion.
But if you want to ask for a beer, for example, with the s sound, you're gonna ask for a cerveza.
If you're gonna ask using the th sound, you're gonna ask for cerveza.
So I would suggest unless you have a particular affiliation with Spain or you particularly want to be practicing with some Spanish friends or whatever to use the S sound
So you have a word like organization that Z as well is going to sound like an S or a T.
Organización.
So you see much easier than this is organization.
Organization.
Good.
Preparation.
Preparación.
Generation.
Generación.
Good.
You had a little bit sipping in from English, right?
One of the vowels there.
But if you take it syllable by syllable, we get every vowel perfect.
Generación.
Confirmation:
Confirmación.
I was tempted to say confermación.
Ah! But you thought "no, i, like ink."
So these are this is actually called language transfer.
So this is negative language transfer.
Things that come from English affecting your Spanish which are not part of Spanish are negative language transfer.
and what is useful from English, so like these convertible words that we are using, as far as language learning is concerned, this is positive language transfer.
So part of our journey here is to identify what is negative language transfer and what is positive language transfer and using both to our advantage.
And English becomes more interesting when we learn Spanish because we start to see where some words come from, where is the inherent wisdom in the vocabulary.
So confirmation, for example, means with signing.
Con is with in Spanish and firma is signature.
So when you confirm you are doing it with signature.
Conversation
Conversation.
Good.
And this means uh like with verses with verse.
Confrontation
Confrontacion.
And front, actually, like in front, comes from frente, which means forehead.
So it's with the forehead.
When you confront, you go forward with the forehead.
Complication.
Complicacion.
Here com is also con, but it changes to an M because of that P.
Happens the same in English and Spanish.
Complicacion.
But this is with folding.
from Latin, plicare, to fold.
So you know when you fold stuff up I guess it gets more complicated.
Something like that.
Now the reason why this is my favorite rule is because out of these words that end in I-O-N, if you take the words that end A Shen
If you take those words and you get rid of the the shun and you put an R on the end, you get the verb.
So let me give you an example.
Preparation, preparacion, preparar
And there you get the verb to prepare.
So there's like a thousand verbs now we know in Spanish.
What was generation?
Generación.
Good.
What is to generate?
Generar.
Good.
What was confirmation?
Confirmacion.
Good.
What is to confirm?
Confirmar.
Yes.
So if you had to guess, how do you think you would say to sign?
If to confirm is with signing.
Firmar.
Yes.
Firmar means to sign.
Complication.
Complicación.
To complicate:
Complicar.
Good.
So now we can make some sentences with this.
What was again I want?
And if we forget that we can think of I love you in Spanish and then take away the you
Quiero.
Quiero. So now we can make some sentences.
I want to prepare:
Quiero preparar.
Good, quiero preparar. How do you say cooperation?
cooperación.
Good,
Good, you pronounced both o's, that was correct.
cooperación.
This sounds a tiny bit longer, no?
To cooperate:
Cooperar.
I want to cooperate:
Quiero cooperar.
Good!
How do you say cancellation?
Cancelación.
And to cancel:
Cancelar.
I want to cancel:
Quiero cancelar.
Good.
How do you think you would say I don't want to cancel?
No quiero cancelar.
Perfect,
exploration:
Exploración.
To explore:
Explorar.
Good.
I want to explore:
Quiero explorar.
Perfect.
The word for me in Spanish is the same as English.
You're just gonna pronounce it how it's written.
me.
Meh.
Good,
How would you say I want to prepare myself?
myself and this means
So you would say, I want to prepare me.
Quiero prepararme.
Good, quiero prepararme. I want to prepare me. I want to prepare myself and this means I want to get ready and you can use this like I want to get ready. Quiero prepararme.
Now this probably sounds quite formal in English.
I want to prepare myself.
But we should be aware that in English Latin words sound especially formal.
Not always.
Cancel doesn't sound formal because it's the only word we use to say cancel.
But most of the time we have two words with similar meanings,
like for example you might have to find and then to encounter which sounds a little bit more formal or a little bit more literary or flowery
And these ones that have these different feelings in English are generally Latin words.
And the Germanic words like find, which in German is finden, same word, sound more everyday, colloquial.
Now we should bear in mind that that's in English, and Latin words in Spanish, which is more Latin, of course don't sound formal, they just sound normal.